bonsoir merci d'être fidèle à ce premier
rendez vous de notre émission pour cette
rentrée littéraire alors d'abord un
débat sulfureux la psychanalyse est elle
une imposture ce sera dans notre
séquence échec et mat
nous avons réuni christine orban et
didier plus plus calme le cours de
littérature que nous donnera paulo
coelho
or le cua lo nous parlera dans un
univers surprenant mais y aura des
surprises par exemple émis un jeune
auteur qui vient de sortir seconde vague
nous émis un auteur qui en veut et qui a
écrit un livre complètement déjanté
véronique olmi pour son dernier roman la
pluie ne change rien aux désirs répondre
à une critique virulente mais aimante de
christian sauvage du journal du dimanche
roger nols pis vous parlera de sa
lecture du journal d'un voleur de jean
genet et surtout de sa rencontre avec
jean genet
une rencontre qui a été déterminante
pour le reste de sa vie à la fin de
cette émission nous voulions vous faire
un cadeau quelqu'un dont on a beaucoup
parlé mais quelqu'un qu'on a connu
michel houellebecq
michel houellebecq pour un journal
intime bien sûr pas très réjouissant
mais vraiment intéressant et vous verrez
émouvant voilà le programme de
l'émission de ce soir je crois qu'il est
temps maintenant de rejoindre
[Musique]
et
bonsoir christine orban didier pleux
vous êtes réunis pour un débat sur la
psychanalyse dans le cadre de notre
séquence
échec et mat alors la psychanalyse est
elle une imposture
didier pleux vous êtes ici le porte
parole d'un collectif d'un ouvrage qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit à la rentrée le
livre noir de la psychanalyse on peut
dire vous avez mis un petit peu la
pagaille dans le landerneau on va y
revenir
en face de vous christine orban qui elle
a écrit un rebond deux fois par semaine
où elle raconte une expérience
personnelle à savoir vous aviez 20 ans
vous étiez marié et votre mari a été
condamné par un cancer vous l'avez
appris vous avez entrepris une
psychanalyse donc c'est une expérience
personnelle contre un brûlot
actuellement c'est vous qui allez
commencer didier pleux dites moi quel
est donc le plus grand péché de la
psychanalyse qui fait que vous vouliez
pendre les psychanalystes
non je crois qu'on ne veut pas les pense
qu'on voulait surtout sait se faire
entendre parce que et une hégémonie et
l'hégémonie de la pensée critique en
france je pense que c'était intéressant
qu'on puisse entendre un autre son de
cloche au niveau psychothérapie
christine orban vous n'êtes pas ici là
alors à présent temps de la psychanalyse
vous avez une expérience en peut dire
même que la psychanalyse vous a sauvé la
vie
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ces
pourfendeurs de la psychanalyse en effet
à répondre que quand tout va mal quand
l'extérieur devient devient fou parce
que la psychanalyse n'est pas là
uniquement quand l'intérieur est
déréglée mais quand l'extérieur ne va
pas donc ça peut arriver dans toutes les
vies
personnellement enfin dans mon histoire
quand on a 20 ans et qu'on n'est pas
assez forte pensée construite pour aider
une personne parce que c'était un cas de
psychanalyse j'ai été pour aider
quelqu'un
j'allais bien je n'avais pas de névrose
qui m'empêchait de vives mais je me
sentais pas assez forte pour aider
quelqu'un quand j'ai appris que mon mari
avait un cancer et avait pour quelques
mois des sachets quelque chose que j'ai
bien compris en lisant vos le dit mais
je disais un petit peu avant l'émission
s'arrête la meilleure pub qu'on puisse
avoir c'est de lire votre livre parce
que je crois que ce qu'on voit dans
votre livre si vous êtes en souffrance
vous n'allez pas bien et on attend on
attend au fil des pages qui se passe
quelque chose il se passe rien ce sens
faites vous rentrez dans une église vous
rentrez dans du silence vous rentrez
dans quelqu'un qui est invisible vous
rentrez avec des odeurs dans le sens où
vous êtes tout seul est d'accord avec ça
et vous aurez des églises
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
parce qu'il se passe beaucoup de choses
à voir si vous faites allusion au
silence
pour moi le silence est un langage et
qu'il faille pu aller à la trappe puis
les moines trappistes rue 89 98 cents
quarante mille francs je vous jure pour
résister
il y avait derrière moi un homme qui me
donnait deux fois par semaine trois
quarts d'heure de son temps un homme
intelligent un homme
un homme qui ne juge pas kim avait un
homme qui suggère quand même vous ne
vous écoute pas il suggère constamment
comme on sait en tout cas même pas du
tout parce qu'on parlait très peu
j'étais plutôt confronté à moi même
c'était un lieu où venir
j'avais un grand secret ah je vous
pouvez le partager avec personne
c'était la seule personne à qui je
pouvais parler donc finalement c'était
c'était devenu vital cet homme et il n'a
pas du tout on n'avait qu'à travailler
comme disent les psys sur le passé la
douleur présentes était beaucoup trop
forte pour aller chercher dans l'enfance
ase ça aurait été très confortable sur
été formidable j'aurais fait un travail
sur moi même j'ai pas pu vous avez une
douleur très très fort elle est l effet
vu qu'il vous il ne vous aidez pas même
besoin de médicaments la fin et lui
prescrit des médicaments temps vous êtes
dépressif il ne vous aide pas il vous
écoute totalement il est empathique
c'est ce qu'on aime bien la psychanalyse
à quelqu'un qui vous écoute quelqu'un
qui nous valorise quelqu'un qui est là
quelqu'un qui est neutre ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'alliance thérapeutique
nous avons aussi il ne traite rien du
tout on peut pas aider quelqu'un qui est
en train de faire la personne qu'il aime
le plus au monde c'est impossible
les mots et pourtant dieu sait que
j'aime les mots sont assez inefficace on
peut par contre c'est comme une bombe à
retardement on prend peut-être de la
force pour survivre plus tard et puis
ces deux fois par semaine ces rendez
vous était comme un
un rite à un rythme dans tous effondrés
au fond de moi c'était comme deux
petites lumières au fond d'un d'un
tunnel vous avez déjà vous avez besoin
de parler en fait il n'y a pas tellement
de parole nous étions pleins de
souffrances passées dans l'eau tu sais
ce que j'ai aussi aimé parce que
tellement c'est ses forces et nous
étions en souffrance puis se passe
jamais rien et comment on faisait quand
vous rentrez chez vous et votre mari qui
était bien là une souffrance terrible
comment vous avez pu survivre à tout ça
vous avez raison c'est s'était
d'ailleurs je me révolte et parfois
parce que ils ne me parlaient pas et
j'étais confronté à moi même ça a été
extrêmement difficile vous étiez lucide
quand vous dites à un moment donné mais
il faut pas être malade pour être guéri
par comme dit à christophe andré l'aps
charisme ne soigne que les bien portants
je suis d'accord avec vous ça a été très
difficile et cette cure à porter ses
fruits longtemps après mais sur le
moment
j'aurais aimé qu'il me parle qui
m'aident qu'est ce que vous auriez fait
sans médication à la fin du communisme
je sais pas si c'est vraiment les
médicaments qui vont aider mais tout de
même être en face d'un d'un homme
humain intelligent qui jugent pas ça a
été une grande aide
mais ça c'est le b à ba de tous les
thérapeutes et empathique bienveillance
neutralité accepter totalement là la
personne qui est devant nous c'est pas
c'est pas que la psychanalyse mais il ya
aussi un anglais faut soigner il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin
quand vous avez commencé votre
psychanalyste vous savez rien en fait
vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs comme on l'a
dit si quelqu'un qui vient défendre la
psychanalyse vous douté et voulez vous
le dit
et pourquoi vous êtes allé vers la
psychanalyse plutôt que vers un autre
mode de traitement de douleur c'est vrai
que au début je ne ferai pas parce que
c'était la psychanalyse moi je venais
d'un pays et d'un milieu où on disait
aux déprimé secoue toi le maroc du maroc
absolument j'ai été élevé au maroc et
quand mon généraliste m'a dit il faut il
faut voir un psychanalyste parce que là
tout ce que vous allez avoir à vivre est
trop dur je lui ai dit je voulais je
suis pas folle pourquoi voulez vous que
je vois pas ce qu'on vous envoie vers un
psychiatre mais le seul choix cette
époque là c'était le divan ou les
médicaments donc les gens choisissaient
de divan que des plannings de marque
chic un peu plusieurs à coude se gaver
de médicaments que peut-on dire à
quelqu'un qui vous dit moi j'ai trouvé
quand même
une réponse une écoute à travers la
psychanalyse que quelqu'un de chaleureux
et quelqu'un qui écouterait peut le
faire aussi mais c'est par un soin parce
que vous vous avez l'intelligence de
voir plusieurs années après que ce
silence prêts à vous apporter
mais moi je pense à tous les enfants les
adolescents qui sont dans les mains de
gens comme ça en ce moment c'est ça la
trêve elle ces gens là n'ont pas le
savoir non pas l'abstraction pour
pouvoir se dire un moment donné qu'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire avec les
dessins avec la symbolique
la psychanalyste et du vent c'est une
belle aventure existentielle mais ça ne
se soigne pas et le problème c'est que
des gens qui vont très mal aidé et
finalement dans cet écrin de silence les
quelques phrases qu'il a prononcées
je les ai jamais oublier et elles m'ont
vraiment aidé à grandir en 96 6 ans
quand on dit deux trois trucs du style
qui vous a aimé quand vous étiez
malheureux c'est des choses qui m'a
aussi de la manipulation ça c'est pas de
l'aide ça ils savent où ils vont
exactement vous descendez trois mots à
manger une fois se trouve pas parce que
je trouve que la compréhension
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'un être
humain puisse faire un autre le
comprendre et de comprendre profondément
et ça on ne tombe pas je vais dire à mon
héroïne entendre le mot juste c'est
comme voir son âme dans un miroir le mot
juste c'est quelque chose qui vous qui
vous éclaire votre la route s'est tout
d'un coup on touche quelque chose et ce
mot juste faut presque le méritaient
faut beaucoup d'heures de travail de
silence de chaque mot qui disait le peu
de mots qui disait devenez absolument
inoubliable et je ne suis pas du tout
fan atiques ni rien eh oui
et on sait le temps c'est ça que je dois
souvent que vous aviez 20 ans vous avez
besoin de comprendre pourquoi la mort
elle frappe comme ça en premier en plein
dans l'amour vous aviez besoin dead et
là je vous trouve et où l'on délivre en
souffrance mais c'est constamment
est ce qu'il va dire quelque chose ce
psy ou de se limer les ongles à ce point
psy quand ils subliment les ongs ce qui
ne vous écoute pas c'est impossible
d'écouter d'un silence c'est pour ça je
me dis quand et se limer les ongles j'ai
l'impression qu'ils se concentrer et
vous savez j'ai été tellement attentive
que je lisais ses silences je les aime
qui valait plus que les gradins
c'est impossible d'écouter quelqu'un
sont répétés sont formulés c'est
impossible c'est scientifiquement prouvé
quand on écoute dans le silence on pense
à autre chose quand il y met ses ongles
penser à saison lui quand il écrivait
sur son carnet et sans doute ses courses
qui ne vous écoutez pas c'est impossible
d'écouter sans être collée à la personne
qu'est ce que vous allez c'est non non
non j'ai suivi une un travail analytique
sur ma pratique quand je m'occupais des
vingt ans non seulement musée pas je
trouve c'est toujours la même chose je
vais retrouver tout le temps la relation
un papa maman la bonne et moi non je
trouve que c'était un peu stérile
ils n'allaient pas assez loin dans
l'inconscient il ya dans ce débat
quelque chose qui a qui est sous jacent
on a l'impression quand même qu'il y
aurait comme un marché du mal à être et
qu'il ya comme une concurrence entre
différentes approches sur ce marché du
malade parce que comme vous le dites
aussi c'est tout ça et du business
derrière il ya de l'argent il ya des
gens qui paient pour pour être qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire à ça est-ce que
vous avez su dans ce cas même si c'est
pour qu'on ait le pouvoir contre une
autre cha touch est actuellement sur
lens ne veut pas c'est qu'une
hégémonique une pensée unique en france
la psychanalyse domine tous les cmpp les
guidances des facs la psychiatrie ont
dit à d'autres choses mais c'est pas
pour prendre le pouvoir
nous c'est le soin qui nous importe ce
sont les gens qui souffrent d'accord
christine or manger vous donner la
parole pour la conclusion qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire à ceux qui vont
lire votre livre et qui vont apprendre
cette expérience dont vous dites qu'elle
vous a sauvé la vie fondamentalement oui
c'est vrai qu'elle m'a sauvé la vie je
pense que c'est un enfin moi je dis de
la psychanalyse c'est une case en plus
vous êtes sûrement pas d'accord mais
et qu'elle a m'a rendu plus attentive je
l'étais déjà j'avais pas besoin
probablement même et aux autres je juge
pas les gens elle m'a appris aussi à
l'impression quand même à faire ce
travail qu'après les psys tout seul
mais faire une psychanalyse juste comme
ça pour faire le voyage je trouve que
non non je moi j'avais un vrai un vrai
malheur une vraie raison d'aller
chercher de l'aide mais mais
mais sans une vraie raison alors c'est
peut-être du luxe être ça marche
beaucoup mieux son réseau mais mais moi
c'était malheureusement avec une vraie
un vrai une vraie douleur on va rester
sur cette conclusion sur sur ces paroles
de douleur je remercie pour ce débat je
pense que chacun ira vers l'un envers
l'autre peut-être vers les deux merci
[Musique]
quand un ex taulard rencontre un ex
taulard banal me direz vous sauf si l'un
et roger knobelspiess à renvoyer
médiatisé des années 80 et l'autre tout
simplement le grand jean genet à partir
de la lecture les journal d'un voleur
roger knobelspiess nous explique combien
la rencontre avec jean genet a été
déterminante pour le reste de son
existence
je suis né à paris le 19 décembre 1910
pupille de l'assistance publique il me
fut impossible de connaître autre chose
de mon état civil
quand j'ai 21 ans j'obtiens un acte de
naissance ma mère s'appelait gabriel
genest mon père reste inconnu
j'ai lu je n'ai ya 25 ans j'étais en
cellule
j'ai une petite table j'écrivais je
reprenais des passages aux jaune et je
prenais jaune et et ses déclarations
d'amour à silly tanoh quoi elle ne
tournait pas de porter stylite anneau
autour du soleil la terre tremble je me
disais mais à comment un homme peut dire
des choses si belle un autre homme moi
je vais les détourner pour les dire à
une femme le sud de jeunesse et il n'y
aura pas d'autres gens jeunes et 16
parce que il faut tellement descendre au
fond de soi-même pour oser dire ça quand
il dit de crachats mais c'est le
couronnement quoi l'idée est là aucune
retenue aucune pudeur aucune morale il
est là boni toutes les frontières
de ce qui fait qu'on peut dire quelque
chose sont bonnes ou mauvaises quoi il
est l'ennemi du bien comme viscéralement
il me dit bien et dans le journal du
voleur et sa carrière risque beaucoup
il est par rapport si vous voulez
approuve quel style d'écriture aussi
intériorisé où les écrivains vont vont
se sont eux-mêmes descendants eux mêmes
vont mieux les lycéens de leur famille
dans un régime et cetera leur petit ego
quoi s'il faut pas intéressant encore
bien jeune et cherche les viscères du
mal c'est parce qu'ils possèdent ces
conditions d'érotisme que je m'acharnais
dans le mal moi je revendique le mal
comme jean genet mois moi je revendique
le mal parce que on est à contresens
on est hors norme et je revendique le
mal jusqu'à hauteur de moi même jusqu à
détester ma ressemblance d'être humain
un moment donné en quantique mansac rire
notre dame des phares en prison il y
revient plus tard dans le journal d'un
voleur et s'explique un peu sur son
écriture et il dit comme ça au détour
d'une phrase qu'il a à la fois cette
dynamique de la déchéance de la
perdition du mal parce que dans le malg
il ya denis richesse humaine qui a pas
drôle bien je rendez vous rue des
martyrs avec son venin
je ne connais je n'ai qu'à travers ses
livres son soutien à la lettre qu'il
m'envoyait en prison la porte du café
s'ouvre le crâne sauver héros s'inscrit
dans l'ouverture un pardessus en poil de
chameau le regard fonctionne à toute
vitesse
on dirait un notaire de province il
m'aperçois lui le vagabond le poète le
voleur les films internet on s'est un
petit peu parlé on l'a lu mon livre qhs
il a senti que dans mon bouquin quelque
chose de du ruisseau du jeune joueur de
poule que j'étais
moi je crois qu'il mène et bien tout de
suite moi je vais parler
à
comme si c'est un dur je disais specta
c'est un dur à cuire quoi je le regarde
fixement qui juge qu' son sourire en
coin survient pas à moi en me fixant à
ces petits tubes l'accrocheur est
coupable aux mains pleines
il ajoute je n'aime pas les innocents et
et comment vas tu existes et combler ces
pavés pour un pauvre lézard vivipare
hasard en la sauce
la société
passants
[Musique]
une graine da
véronique olmi bonsoir alors merci
d'avoir accepté de participer à notre
séquence ping pong c'est sur un petit
peu douloureux on répond à une critique
pas forcément très très positives à
propos de son dernier ouvrage
alors votre dernier ouvrage c'est la
pluie ne change rien aux désirs alors je
voudrais pour pour parler de votre livre
lire ce que vous en dites
et pour voir un petit peu d'où vient
cette incompréhension parfois avec
certaines critiques
mon roman c'est la rencontre dans un
hôtel le temps d'un après-midi orageux
d'un homme et d'une femme qui vont jouir
ensemble jusqu'à s'offrir un peu
d'insouciance retrouvé le goût de
l'innocence de l'indulgence et du pardon
c'est le dernier mot du livre le pardon
et c'est vrai que c'est un livre sur la
rédemption et
quand les critiques
sont pas favorables aux leafs et
qu'elles ont occulté totalement cette
dimension alors on va voir la critique
dont on parle c'est celle de christian
sauvage dans le journal du dimanche mais
pas tout à fait sa critique et c'est ça
qu'il ya de singulier alors écoutons
christian sauvage parler de la plus ne
change rien au désir chez véronique
denis
je voudrais vous expliquer pourquoi vous
n'aurez pas de papiers sur votre dernier
il dans le journal du dimanche
est-ce que vous pouvez arrêter parce que
je trouve que c'est quelque chose de
singulier quelqu'un vous dit qu'il n'y
aura pas de papiers sur votre libre mais
parce qu'en fait il là il a l'air déçu
de ne pas avoir aimé oui alors j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt je suis je
suis désolé ça m'a pas pu cesser ça n'a
pas l'air d'être le papier
je jouis mais ça existe mais je crois
c'est mary bale se soient mutuellement
vous êtes raté ça arrive c'est pas très
grave mais vous ne ferez plus vous pétri
simplement des creux alors ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
moi je suis d'accord avec lou et j'ai
pas du tout voulu effleuré et moi je le
propos du livre justement c'est d'y
aller quoi si je parle d'une rencontre
amoureuse et d'une rencontre physique
entre un homme et une femme en
l'occurrence je vais pas envie de faire
ma cherches à te dire ah j'en parle mais
un petit peu moi j'avais envie d'être
d'oser être dans au plus près du
processus du
du désir sans volonté de choquer ça peut
pas choqué parce que c'est jamais
violent s'est jamais en provocation
s'est jamais contre c'est un homme et
une femme 45 entend donc relativement à
dieuze moselle consentants et qui vont
faire que des choses bonnes
l'un pour l'autre et l'un avec l'autre
en communion tout le temps les pluies ne
change rien au désir c'est l'histoire
d'un homme et d'une femme qui se
rencontre on sait pas très bien et ils
sont on va découvrir quelques éléments
d'un livre il se rend compte et pendant
une trentaine de pages ils vont
s'envoyer en l'air dans un hôtel ça
c'est génial parce que en fait il dit
ils vont s'envoyer en l'air en soit
notre monde c'est très paradoxal parce
que moi je met en scène deux personnes
alors 100 pages d'érotisme non c'est
faux parce qu'en fait il ya le livre est
composé en trois parties il ya trois
tiers il ya la rencontre
ils sont rencontre classe saint sulpice
et mon jardin du luxembourg il ya la
chambre d'hôtel et il ya tous apprennent
c'est-à-dire il ya le repos partagé il
ya le dialogue
l'histoire de l'un et de l'autre qui se
dénoue et lui dit s'envoyer en l'air
alors c'est paradoxal parce qu'à l'image
d'être en l'air et en même temps c'est
une phrase qui fera baisser cette
violence etc en voilà non ils font pas
l'amour ils s'envoient en l'air
et alors moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que oui il décolle et d'ailleurs
il ya une phrase du livre qui dit il se
passe c'est autre chose que la vie ici
bas
il se passe l envol le plaisir absolu et
le mystère et le désir une énigme b
légumes
le problème c'est qu'après le livre
l'énigme oui il a raison les mines mais
pas résolus mais moi je me bats clinique
me soit résolu parce que pour moi
le plaisir c'est un mystère donc c'est
pour ça que j'avais envie de travailler
là dessus c'est pas quelque chose c'est
que je peux mettre en équation que je
peux résoudre c'est tout passe à travers
la sensation dans le livre les odeurs
donc est-ce que ça trimballe qu'est ce
qu'on imagine de l'autre d'où il vient
de la façon de fumer la façon de
déboucher une bouteille de vin au rituel
de cigares oui mes yeux c'est très
ritualisé essai c'est presque ça peut
presque être ringard c'est à dire que
l'homme il est à sa place d'homme et
l'afld et voilà fait son travail d'homme
il fait son travail d'homme et je me
demande si c'est pas la ksa juste comme
ça ça chapeau n'est pas toujours très
bien qui est cette femme
on sait qu'elle a des enfants on sait
qu'elle a refusé de signer l'internement
de son mari qui souffre de psychose elle
même est en très mauvaise santé
elle sent beau sortir dans un des récifs
quatre icônes en effet c'est génial
parce que l on sache je vois pas où il a
pris je ne sais pas où
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans le livre
c'est pas des athlètes de magazines
ils sont pas jeunes ils sont pas
forcément beau ils ont des complexes
elle se retrouve trop maigre il est un
petit peu gros et puis sont un peu
cabossés par la vie ces deux solitudes
qui se rencontrent et qui vont se sauver
par la rencontre et alors là c'est
génial parce qu'il dit elle sort d'un
hôpital psychiatrique ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire elle est dans la marge
alors que cette femme oui elle est
beaucoup beaucoup faire l'amour mais
elle est pas mal en voisins de l est pas
malade
elle aime ça c'est tout quant à l'homme
en dehors de la taille de celle que on
se fait un peu creux j'adore est-ce que
et celle inverse du livre tel que
libellé pas dans la performance et ça ça
réflexe ce petit garçon qui a la plus
grande quand on pisse derrière platanes
et nous les femmes on s'en fout un
franchement est alors pas une seconde
elle est le deal at elle dit par contre
et ça je le revendique
elle dit ce qu'elle ressent dans un
temps se demande si on n'est pas tombé
un petit peu dans ce genre de milieu
je vous cite un passage je vais arrêter
là ça m'a réveillée parce que c'est
marrant il dit elle a l'air est de
sortie d'un hôpital psychiatrique elle
va très mal du mois de l'histoire de
villiers
moi je le lis pas bon je pense qu'il les
connaît mieux que moi mais moi je
connais les couvertures elles ont l'air
en volume est pas forcément l'erreur on
est dans la pornographie c'est à dire
que c'est l'argent avec l'érotisme et
c'est la violence en général sont des
flingues et les flingues sur les nichons
mois celle inverse le roman c'est pas
dans la violence et c'est pas dans la
provocation mais c'est drôle parce que
ils essayent de rendre pornographiques
et donc gérard de villiers je sais pas
je le lis pas mais c'est intéressant de
voir où il place la virilité nous
prenons un passage secret mais quand
même vous l'écrit elle sentit ses doigts
dans sur son cul habiletés de ses doigts
alter glisser son string de faire cela
souvent une habitude un point de passage
obligé vers glisser la strychnine femme
elle se souleva se leva elle était
debout depuis sur se battent à trop mou
il démarrait tout en bas entre ses
jambes écartées c'était peut-être cela
dominion est génial parce qu'ils
arrêtent la phrase là c'est pas fini la
phrase justement c'est c'était peut-être
cela dominer un homme le regard des du
ciel sans savoir s'il sera généreux ou
pressé c'était peut-être cela dominer un
homme mais elle venait du pays de la
peur et elle savait que cette peur ne la
lâcherai jamais alors effectivement si
11h l'émission le tronçonner c'est pour
ça qu'au début j'étais content que vous
commencez par le mot pardon parce
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas toute la spiritualité
et la mystique du livre et c'est ce qui
fait c'est à dire qu'il prend un début
de la phrase dominé alors on est dans
les salles aux murs elle est au dessus
de lui elle domine un css mais dans mes
idées pas la phrase en entier et que
justement ce cliché de dominer un homme
est complètement anéanti par la
fragilité de cette femme la fragilité du
plaisir et du désir et de la rencontre
et c'est ce qui en fait sa noblesse jeu
donc c'est une sorte de lecture ainsi
tour on aura remarqué c'est que vous
connaissez par coeur
j'ai même un sou mais voilà rappeneau et
les jambes galbées
mais alors il me reproche qui est pas
les jambes galbées mais juste prix sont
à baugy peuvent pas aller voir les
jambes galbées ils sont pas beaux suis
désolé c'est pas alors il ya des moments
où on se perd un petit peu dans ce set
et cumulation je serai je vous ferai
grâce la pipe dans la baignoire et de
quelques autres c'est denis menchov le
dire ce n'est pas le dire je vous ferai
grâce de la vie dans la ville majeure
parce que en étant il en parle
il veut parler et alors la pire dans la
vie comme ça me gêne pas d'en parler
c'est un moment d'allégresse est un jeu
et parce que dans ce livre justement
elle a pleuré la des pleurs et il ya de
la joie
il ya de la pudeur et ya de l'impudeur
il y à l'abandon il ya de la possession
et tout le livre joue sur ses registres
la paire d'autrefois ou dans
l'impression qu'on n'arrive pas à mettre
des mots sur les choses
mettre les mots sur les sentiments c'est
pourtant de travailler dans des trucs
alors c'est le travail d'un écrivain il
s'est arrêté
luz
[Musique]
le travail d'un écrivain alors ça veut
dire là leurs proches ça veut dire que
les critiques qui ont aimé les libraires
qui me défende et l'électorat très fort
et les lecteurs que je rencontre ne font
pas leur travail d'un travail de
lecteurs c'est quoi la graine de
lecteurs alors au travail de critique et
de libraires ce que je voudrais dire ce
que lui a jamais parlé du style quand
même invité littéraire on parle pas du
tout du lys du style on parle pas donc
il a occulté deux tiers du livre qui
coupe les phrases et moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose il ya une femme qui est venue voir
récemment chez dans un salon et elle m'a
élevé mon âge à peu près et elle m'a dit
voilà je savais pas je pensais que
j'étais tout seul à avoir peur je savais
pas qu'on pouvait avoir peur dans la
relation amoureuse et que ce soit normal
moi je voudrais terminer sur une chose
oui c'est beau la peur la pudeur et
l'appréhension et le trac dans la
relation amoureuse mais ce dont je ne
veux pas avoir peur c'est d'oser en
parler il mon travail d'auteur puisque
c'est ça qui a remis en cause
c'est justement de ne pas effleuré de
dire mais j'en passe je l'écris j'espère
et je crois que vous a donné l'occasion
d'en parler je pense que les gens qui
nous ont écoutés vont avoir très envie
de lire ce roman là plus ne change rien
aux désirs est ce que vous auriez un
dernier mot à dire à christian sow mais
un dernier mot à tirer je trouve que
ce que j'aime dans sa critique c'est que
justement c'est ce que je disais au
début il n'y a pas la jouissance du bon
mauvais papier c'est à dire je vais je
vais montrer comme j'écris bien un
descendant quelqu'un donc tu marches
dessus pour m'élever ça c'est pas du
tout ça là dedans c'est bon je sais ni à
distance très forte du louvre oui mais
du fait peut-être une grande implication
avec tubize à se brouiller
alors l'occurrence je pense que tout le
monde a été moi j'étais assez ébloui par
la façon dont vous avez répondu à
christian sauvage
je n'avais pas besoin de l'être mais je
pense que beaucoup de téléspectateurs
vont comme je l'avais dit soleure avoir
envie de lire votre livre
merci beaucoup à vous en tout cas
bon
[Applaudissements]
e
pour notre cours de littérature ce soir
paulo coelho nous parle d' henri muller
par locaux loués tout simplement le
deuxième moteur le plus lu dans le monde
je ne vous dirai pas qui est le premier
seulement l'alchimie ça a été vendu à 7
millions cinq cent mille exemplaires le
zaïre son dernier roman prend le même
chemin alors quel rapport entre l'auteur
de ce roman initiatique et henri muller
qu'elle fascination pour le tropique du
cancer c'est ce que va nous dire
maintenant paulo pruvost alors un
régulière c'était pour moi une
découverte je suis allé vers les livres
dans et müller pas parce que c'est un
grand écrivain au contraire c'était
interdit oresys est interdit même aux
états unis la france était le seul pays
j'essaie d'aller vers tropique du cancer
pour des raisons d'abord parce que c'est
interdit
les aimants parce que parler du sexe de
la pornographie idiot ça doit être
intéressant alors un garçon avec 17 ans
18 ans avec beaucoup d'intérêt pour le
sujet et un jour j'ai vu des vingt
exemplaires
des trucs qui se passait j'ai commencé à
lire c'était vraiment un et quand j'ai
commencé à lire les livres et je vis
qu'il avait un g2 vraie vie dans ses
livres et là je crois qu' henri milet il
a toujours détesté les cours de
littérature
j'étais persuadé mais par contre la
bonne façon de décrire son âme son
expérience c'était la meilleure
description des paris qui je vis dans
toute ma vie et même quand je suis
revenu il ya deux ans je relis lettres
but de concert avec cette peur d'être
déçu parce que parfois un acteur en
écrivant vous vous marque beaucoup et
après après vous êtes déçus et non
encore c'est un classique pour moi bon
et quand je lis rhin rémy l'air et sa
façon d'écrire
eq spontanée enthousiaste alors ouverte
et c'était vraiment les grands maîtres
pour moi de l'écriture et depuis que je
les concerts je dis presque toute son
oeuvre il ya des livres que j'aime bien
il ya des livres que j'aime moi mais
quand même à hilla il a marqué ma vie et
un jour j'étais au japon il y a trois
ans et j'ai dit c'est un début les
journalistes posaient toujours la même
question comme une pause
quels sont vos écrivains préférés il se
verra et je dis bonjour à mado les
brésiliens borghese henri muller et la
traductrice interprète elle était
paralysée elle m'a dit mais henri muller
g8
j'ai pensé qu'elle était un peu vexé de
les traduire et gilles quand la
l'interview terminée à la dgi non non je
n'ai pas vu que vous voulez connaître la
femme de régleur j'ai dû bien sûr mais
quel bonheur
alors ce soir nous sommes allés d
hambach horrible totalement vides il y
avait la femme d'henry muller là dans
l'est-var tout seul elle avait un petit
musée au fond du bar et avec les photos
le thème avec lui pendant vingt ans il
nous avons beaucoup discuté la façon d
henri muller écrire c'était presque une
écriture automatique mais totalement
différent de l'érable grillé par exemple
il avait cette tendance à la vie
expression des coins secrets qui ont
caché toujours bon et je lui dis mais
qu'est ce que vous faites ici allez dis
je fais la même chose que j'ai fait que
je faisais quand j'ai rencontré un rémy
lien pour la première fois j'avais 20
ans les terres losange allaitent
j'étudie à los angeles et je jouais du
piano de chanson française
un japonais un japonais
bon il avait ni il avait 60 ans une
différence d'âge de gigantesques est bon
il a tombé amoureux nous avons moyens
mais surtout je crois qu'il ya dans
l'oeuvre d'henry miller
une expo tanit et qui sait difficile
vraiment difficile de trouver ne les
autres écrivent il est quelqu'un qui
sait partager la main avec des mots qui
fait du sens parce que parfois on essaie
de compliqué trop pour l'écriture nous
on va on commence à passer trop est-il
différent mais on passe pas à la main à
les choses qui sont au delà des mots et
dans les cases d'un riz muller même si
son est-il c'était la liberté totale
comme c'était sa vie bon il avait cette
énergie cette puissance de vivre dans
chaque mot collective et seul écrivain
qui m'a beaucoup marqué parce que
surtout pour lui la littérature c'est
pep s'était pas en cours c'était
vraiment partagé son âme comme c'est
pour moi
[Musique]
ont versé par le ciss comprend bien la
france doit paulo coelho à henri muller
la possibilité d'une île est le dernier
roman de michel houellebecq qui ne le
sait pas et pour ce journal intime
je pourrais vous dire michel houellebecq
comme on vous l'a toujours promis michel
houellebecq comme vous l'avez jamais vu
et pourtant c'est exactement ça et vous
allez voir que dans ce journal intime
michel houellebecq se livre et s'expose
comme il ne l'a jamais fait depuis bien
longtemps
[Musique]
c'est sûr de toi
fait
au centre métro se justifier
qui est méritée
sion
oui je fais je suis pas quelqu'un de
trésors c'est vrai que mon journal
intime n'est pas intéressant
c est pas de
pas de révélations fracassantes rien
[Rires]
vraiment c'est vrai dans une
rose intime
mais aussi socialement je reste très
classe foyer
la seule chose où
op normal c'est
je pensais que je retourne tout mieux
que les autres
ils ont pris ce qui me concerne
mais j'ai l'impression depuis le début
et devoirs des instruments dean eric des
yeux plissés
comme je venu
un poster
je pense à comprendre les chemins star
public
justement connu pour rencontrer par
hasard de abreu vie des gens qui m'ont
l'udc
c'est pas ça c'est le sens
[Musique]
je vous
c'est quoi ce monde
monsieur je peux faire
monsieur m
nous on pardonner mais
et
des silences
dix ans
sa chose que je
ce monsieur
et puis
sur le site
vim
là
st
l'ado
il
ce
comme ça
non l'image moi je peux vraiment des
exceptions ya toujours sept suivantes
jours m
il n'empêche que les gens ont
globalement décidé qu'ils
s'intéressaient à moi qui s'intéresse
pas du tout et rien de ce que je
pourrais écrire et polis intel en plus
considérable
c'est cox isild trouvable en couleurs
culturel après les persuade existe un
fils de laine qui vise à taxer me
pratiquement à m'agresser parce que je
voulais pas reconnaître que j'avais fait
du bien
sur cet amour
c'est un peu une femme
la pression de cette adaptation de son
coup
je croyais l'avoir se met fin de l'es7
[Rires]
on y verra mois
alors
boom du billard damon
globe vous rappelle quelque chose la
bière a
[Musique]
parent
oh
un hématome ce constat n'est pas
[Musique]
j'ai mis mon soir bonsoir
je vais d'abord vous vous présentez vous
êtes nos petites attendu donc vous êtes
né au cameroun à douala
vous avez 30 ans on sera comme ça et ce
birdman blues qui est le roman dont nous
allons parler est votre premier roman
alors je vais dire un peu de quoi il
s'agit j'aime dire c'est d'accord avec
cette présentation de votre mans alors
ce roman c'est l'histoire d'un mec comme
derek l'onu il est noir musiciens lévis
en banlieue
ils croient qu'on peut s'en tirer en
pensant plutôt qu'en d'ilan est ce que
c'est ça un peu l'histoire de ce mec
oui c'est un peu ça mais ce mec est ce
que c'est vous non pas tout à fait ça
pourrait être moi de toute façon vous
êtes écrivain vous savez bien qu'il ya
toujours beaucoup de soin dans ce conte
est revenu mais une fois que le j'ai
lâché à la fois ce n'est plus tout à
fait nous qu'est-ce qu'elle voulut férié
mais en écrivant ce livre est bien ce
que j'ai voulu faire tout d'abord c'est
matérialisé l'ambiance de la banlieue
mais une banlieue qui à un moment donné
parce qu'une danse que les heureux
appelle l'autre côté du cerveau c'est à
dire que au début du livre il ya cette
ambiance effectivement qu'on peut
reconnaître aisément c'est que pour ceux
qui connaissent un petit peu la peau et
les poncifs mésaventure voilà c'est ça
et d'ailleurs bien souvent ici sont tout
simplement pour être démolies
un peu plus tard voilà mais c'est vrai
que ce que je vous le fais c'est de
symboliser le tournage on va le dire de
la banlieue avant le basculement de
l'autre côté du cerveau peut être
salvateur alors ce tournage en rond pour
y échapper on a l'impression que amy se
raconte des histoires pour aller vers un
espèce d'ailleurs idéalisé qui serait le
nid riaume alors qu'est ce que c'est que
cette année rien alors l'honneur et
hommes comme son nom l'évoqué un petit
peu d'ailleurs le lyrisme voilà et c'est
une terre où les rêves sont censés
incarner et puis enquêter dans la
réalité pour enfin exulter
voilà c'est 100 en fait ça dit le but à
atteindre
ça ne ce n'est pas forcément la grosse
fortune ou quoi que ce soit mais la
réalisation
du soin de soi voilà absolument mais
alors on a l'impression aussi que pour
pour atteindre cet omnium il faut passer
par des chemins
on a passé un peu hâlé prophétique ou
christique est-ce que c'est nouvelle
bible franchement c'est vrai que le
héros qui est très mystique vont être
dit à un moment donné je suis lutter
savez je suis l'ultime testament est en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui souffre c'est
quelqu'un qui souffre qui tourne
beaucoup par on est à un moment donné
dès lors qu'ils décident de basculer de
l'autre côté du cerveau parce que les
oiseaux en fait tu lui apportes ces
messages là à travers une voix qu'il
entend le matin bonne foi ajoute à cela
qu il était un petit peu un état de
conscience altérée il avait fumé
oui consommons qui on manquerait mais on
se demande quand même fondamentalement
si la drogue la plus dure dans ce livre
ce n'est pas le langage
oui absolument écrire c'est sortir du
ventre du rat vous voyez que en banlieue
on a souvent l'impression qu'on est dans
le ventre durera une espèce de chose en
close dans lequel on est constamment en
train de se buter le front contre les
murs oui mais alors pour pouvoir sentir
sortir du ventre du rat pour pouvoir
faire ce travail sur cette langue
il ya une certaine culture c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire d'où lui vient
cette culture d'où vient cette de
l'auteur et bien moi je suis né au
cameroun dans une famille plutôt aisée
va dire
les familles royales même parce qu'on
trouve jamais de traces de vos origines
dans un dossier de presse on sait pas
d'où vous vient oui parce que je n'ai
pas forcément envie de le directement
harel d'origine royal non c'est pas ça
mais simplement je suis pas non plus
albert de monaco s'est passé mais c'est
vrai que j'ai grandi dans une famille où
il y avait beaucoup de livres beaucoup
de gens lettrés des journalistes dès que
faisaient nos parents si on a le droit
de le savoir en quoi que ce soit c'est
une longue histoire
j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes avec mes
parents qui mangeait pas et je n'ai pas
connu mon père j'ai été élevé par ses
grands-parents midi
donc en fait mon grand père que j'étais
pour lui son fils comme son dernier bon
sens un sens la fascination du grand
père est là le père qui manquait le papa
celui qu'on va appeler papa alors yenni
se nouent et se nourrit de quoi quel
lyonnais se nourrit de tout ça et puis
de la littérature sa part de baudelaire
qui m'a mené aux lettres en est à
beckett james bond les deux sont ralliés
d'ailleurs parce que beckett a été
professeur ses prêteurs de johnny
donc c'est vrai qu'il y aurait un lien
tout à fait naturel qu'on se marre
whitman appareils oui il ya huit mois
des huit mille feuilles d'herbe et et
puis à céline mieux c'est le travail sur
la langue
céline m'a beaucoup inspiré le travail
sur la langue par c'est la liberté la
liberté de pouvoir dit on est gros
hupin oui le politiquement correct c'est
pas venir haricots et c'est que parce
que tout je suis tout ça voyez vous je
suis tout ça je vis avec daignac oui je
vis avec des boules
donc je suis tout ça absolument quoi
donc ça me dérange pas ça ne se sont que
des mots vous savez oui on a le
sentiment dans la dernière phrase que
c'est une ode métissage oui absolument
il ya de ça aussi bien sûr je fais de la
musique depuis 15 ans aussi
même si mon travail c'est d'écrire oui
on travaille c'est l'écrit mais j'ai
intégré depuis longtemps la musique
comme faisant partie de ma littérature
sadique c'est une démarche littéraire
pour moi la musique nous et dans la
musique il ya beaucoup de métissage sa
part du reggae à l'afro jazz etc
j'ai l'impression que l'espèce de
babylone vers laquelle on va c'est pari
que je retrouve les mii sur devant
beaubourg sur la pizza est comme une
espèce d'aboutissement
il ya même je me trompe peut-être une
espèce dodd à jacques chirac
est ce que je me trompe est ce qu'il ya
une espèce d achat jacques chirac dans
dans le sens un petit peu un petit
phrase alors lui parce que
jacques chirac au mans j'ai pas digéré
le bruit et les odeurs paris j'étais en
galère aussi à l'époque et le bruit et
l'odeur c'est vrai que ça m'est resté en
travers
à ma connaissance peut-être qu'il a fait
mais à ma connaissance il s'est jamais
excusé vraiment là-dessus
donc moi en tant que black vivant en
france et surtout après les événements
qui se sont dits sûrs voilà le style des
cépages donc voila c'était donc du coup
un peu d'anti phrase pour notre
président est d'accord
alors ce que je voudrais demander
maintenant parce que moi ça m'intéresse
que va devenir ce que je sais que c'est
le premier volet d'un triptyque très
bien ça et il est déjà en écriture
oui et il est dense danse est dans cette
veine dans cette ligne est la seule une
écriture avec une musicalité dont on va
dire un sombre ayant voyez comme on
dirait pour un risque c'est un son
brillant le prochain aura peut-être une
sonorité plus mat
parce que là la musique avait peut-être
trop évidente oui mais c'était fait
exprès la démarche celle là
donné jusqu'au bout plein les tympans
par son gré ses muscles oui parce que
disons les lignes ne sont pas simplement
visibles et sont audibles mais quand on
lit on entend oui on entend le roi là on
entend bien sûr absolument
et voilà donc le prochain livre on
l'entendre appareils en même temps que
le lira mais ce sera un sont peut-être
un peu plus mat d'accord bon on l'attend
avec avec impatience et vous ne serez
plus l'inattendu on vous recevra
certainement dans dans café picouly
parce que je suis certain que yemi ça va
aller loin
j'espère bien c'est merci beaucoup de
m'avoir
david quand je te vois tu agitée comme
ça ça veut dire que on va bientôt fermer
enfin écoute avant de fermer je voudrais
te conseiller un livre c'est mon livre
préféré cette semaine akli tadjer
alphonse les histoires d'un petit gamin
dans les années 60 dans le nord de la
france
il s'appelle mohamed et il doit se faire
appeler alphonse voir c'est très
touchant très émouvant et drôle
voilà c'est le livre que que j'aimerais
que tu dises avec plaisir merci aux
locaux bon j'espère que tu as passé une
bonne soirée
excellente merci non je crois qu'on va
on va fermer
[Musique]
en tout cas ma bascule avec un jour
non
[Musique]
et
l'année passée
[Musique]